there's more to the border crisis than
just the ongoing surge of migrants
and that's the staggering amount of
deadly drugs flooding into the country
border agents have seized more fentanyl
in the last seven months
than the entire year before so far this
year customs and border patrol
have seized nearly 6 500
pounds of the synthetic opioid which
rockets past the over 4 000 pounds
seized all last year
and keep this in mind we've had over 90
000 overdoses in the u.s over the last
year
largely due to fentanyl which is around
50 times more potent than heroin
just one kilogram has the potential to
kill a half a million people
that according to the dea all right it's
clear what the strategy the cartels is
you know you distract border patrol with
the children and the families because
biden does catch and release now and you
just send massive amounts of single men
over the border
and border patrol agents are stretched
in at the ports of entry
so fentanyl is just pouring across juan
what is the strategy of the biden
administration
to actually deter these types of
crossings
well obviously better enforcement and
what does better enforcement mean jesse
it means
that since most of the drugs coming into
the united states come through
legal courts of entry not through
illegal crossings or people jumping the
wall or swimming
across the rio grande or digging a
tunnel but through legal ports of entry
what it means is that you have more
agents at the those legal
ports to inspect cargo remember we've
got the busiest
border in the world our southern border
you got
i'm sorry there's actually less
border patrol agents policing the ports
of entry because they're stretched thin
on all the other crossing areas it's
true one
no so what you had what you had during
the trump era was he was moving
agents the custom and border patrol
agents away from the port of entries
with this focus on the wall and illegal
immigrants crossing
the courts it backed up
so it backed up it backed up the lines
of people
at the legal ports of entry they can own
those lines can only be so
long in terms of time duration so you
had more of the illegal drugs pouring
through
and that's why we said people were
idling their trash for a year people
died no they weren't idling they were
coming through with the illegal drugs
jesse
that doesn't make any sense greg 90
000 ods i mean that's a lot of dead
americans
i i mean and in this particular angle
when we're talking about the border it
it reflects a greater underlying problem
which uh and
just you're gonna disagree with me but
you gotta hear me out that this
is a problem due to a fail the failed
war on drugs the the war on drugs has
driven
millions of people to street concoctions
like fentanyl which are poorly measured
poorly controlled and kill you
you have absolutely no idea how many
americans have died over the last two
decades
famous people in which the coroner
always said
overdose or died in his sleep when it
was a drug
laced with fentanyl which is a far more
complex description
than just saying they died from heroin
this is something that when you put it
into
anything it kills you but people are
willing to take the risk
because they are seeking their own
particular brand of oblivion which they
can't buy legally unfortunately they're
not into tequila
or cigarettes they want to get high so
you have 50 000 dead a year in this case
90 000 because of the pandemic
all is coming through the border and
through these ports of entry but it's
made in china
it's made in china so the solution is if
you legalize drugs you would create
clean manageable product just like the
tequila
just like the cigarettes that would kill
the black market which would
dramatically reduce
the gory violence in every country and
at the border because we are no longer
their best customer
because we're always going to be their
best customer this debate will never go
away until it's legalized
yeah you're right about china for sure
but i didn't know there was people
having a hard time getting them
hands on pills they know um you hear
you hear about you hear about what is it
a microgram
can is fatal so it's almost impossible
to detect
how do you crack down on something like
that well one of the things that the
government should do and i believe the
trump administration tried but i think
that this administration needs to
redouble its efforts issue one of the
things is killing it at its source
and put the pressure on the chinese to
figure out a way to stop this from
happening but are the chinese
incentivized to do that
no and then when we talk about the
border issue
being more than just something that's
happening on the southwest border it's
that
all of these drugs and these cartel
members that are able to get across
they are flooding the rest of the
country with it and
here's an idea i mean if i were kamala
harris the first woman vice president
who had a background in law enforcement
this is the issue i would take
on i would raise my hand and say i'll do
the triangle diplomacy stuff but this
issue
this matters to american families right
now and i would try to
get in front of that and lead
yeah dagon i would probably have the daa
dea just start boarding
chinese ships at random or if you
designate the mexican cartels terror
groups you could drone strike the labs
yeah and instead according to governor
abbott just in april the department of
public safety seized enough fentanyl to
kill all of new york state
every person in the state that's how bad
the problem is
and so without hesitation biden and co
created this golden opportunity for drug
traffickers and violent criminals and
human traffickers
so they've allowed this they've created
an environment that allows people to
profit from and get rich off of human
misery and then they have the audacity
to act like because the borders now wide
open that they're doing something
virtuous instead it's vomitous
good word yeah and as the coveted deaths
go down
you're going to see the opioids tick
right back up and that's going to be the
biggest plague hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else